-Thank you very much!
And welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, we have
some good news from overseas
in the fight against COVID.
Watch this.
-The UK approved
the Pfizer vaccine.
It makes the UK
the first Western country
to give a vaccine to the public
outside of trials.
-Wow!
Everyone there
will have access
to the Pfizer vaccine.
Apparently, the UK is now
five hours
and five months ahead of us.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Americans heard and were like,
"I watch 'The Crown.'
Does that mean I can get it?"
[ Laughter ]
The news is so good,
people in UK
got this close
to showing emotion.
[ Laughter ]
[ English accent ]
I feel a tear coming on.
Fight it!
[ Laughter ]
But this is interesting --
there's an order
for who gets the vaccine first.
It goes
codgers, hags, blokes, mums,
and, last,
[ English accent ] wankers.
[ Laughter ]
That was interesting.
These are some strange times.
Right, now Americans are looking
at leader of the UK
and thinking,
"I wish we had that guy
in charge."
[ Laughter ]
The vaccine over there
is actually the same
as American one.
The only difference is
the British one
is drier and more sarcastic.
[ Laughter ]
I love that joke.
Meanwhile, I saw that
Vladimir Putin said Russia
will also start vaccinating
their people next week.
Yeah, the vaccine seems
like a winner.
5 out of 5 Russian doctors
recommend it.
[ Slavic accent ]
If they know
what's good for them.
[ Laughter ]
And this is great --
Russia's already working
on a vaccine for whatever is
in that vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, I'd eat sushi
in Iowa on a Tuesday
before I'd trust
a vaccine in Russia.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, some big news
from Washington.
Yesterday, it came out
that President Trump
might give Rudy Giuliani
a preemptive pardon.
Well, now, he's thinking
about the same thing
for his son-in-law,
Jared Kushner;
and his kids Ivanka,
Eric, and Don Jr.
Some families get each other
sweaters for Christmas.
The Trumps get pardons.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump said he wants
to focus
on taking care
of his loved ones,
those closest to him,
and Eric.
[ Laughter ]
It's not a great look
for your presidency
when your biggest
accomplishment is
"Most Family Members Pardoned."
[ Laughter ]
It's pretty crazy.
The last person
who needed pardons
for whole family
was Charles Manson.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-Meanwhile, Mike Pence
is also asking for a pardon,
for the time
he accidentally glanced
at a picture of Kate Upton.
[ Laughter ]
[ Drums play ]
Mother!
It happened!
It happened again!
[ Laughter ]
It was scary for me,
but I slept it off.
[ Laughter ]
Face-down on the couch.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, everybody,
Trump is busy.
Last night he hosted
a White House Christmas party.
He hosted a party.
And he made a pretty big
announcement. Listen to this.
-Overnight, President Trump
touting his success,
hinting at the inevitable,
and suggesting
another possible run
for the White House.
-Melania heard that
and was like,
if you think I'm decorating
this stupid house again,
you're nuts!"
[ Laughter ]
Really,
another Trump presidency?
That's like the director
of "Cats" announcing a sequel.
[ Laughter ]
You can tell Trump's serious
about running again
because already claiming
the 2024 election is rigged.
[ Isolated laughs ]
If Trump --
Thank you, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
Always count on you, buddy.
If Trump won in 2024,
he'd be the first president
to serve nonconsecutive terms
since Grover Cleveland,
which Trump thinks is
the full name
of the fuzzy blue Muppet.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, in four years,
Trump's either going to be
the president
of the United States
or the cohost
of "American Ninja Warrior."
[ Laughter ]
But there was actually
another video taken
of Trump's big announcement.
I don't know
if you've seen this thing.
Listen to this.
-[ Coughing ]
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
[ Coughing ]
-Ew!
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh! A party without masks,
people coughing everywhere.
Next, Trump's going to celebrate
the eight nights of Hanukkah
at Walter Reed.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, earlier tonight,
NBC aired the
88th Annual Rockefeller Center
Christmas Tree Lighting
and I have to say
the tree looks amazing.
It's somewhere between 75
and 80 years old
and good news -- at that age,
the tree will be one
of the first
to receive the vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
If you plan on seeing
the tree in person,
it'll stay lit every day
from 6:00 am to midnight,
pretty much like every parent
homeschooling their kids.
[ Laughter ]
But, due to COVID,
visitors can only see the tree
for five minutes.
In response, Dads were like --
[ Changes accent ]
What are we supposed to do
with the other four
and a half minutes?
[ Laughter ]
See it?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, thank you.
Wow, applause?
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
I heard that Drake
is now selling a scented candle
that smells like
himself.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine being a scientist
and your boss is like,
"I'm pulling you
off the COVID vaccine
so you can work
on the Drake candle."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, Drake said it's not
even pronounced "Drake."
It's pronounced "Drah-ké."
[ Laughter ]
-Ew!
-That's right,
the Drake candle smells like
musk, ambers, cashmere,
suede, and velvet.
I, on the other hand,
smell like Speed Stick,
everything bagels, and Purell.